the American Idol finale winner and
runner-up reveal they're dating while
John Legend shares how they came up with
his new son's name plus we've got your
summer TV preview love was in the air at
the American Idol finale did you guys
catch this 20 year old Maddie poppy was
named the newest American Idol but not
before runner-up Caleb Lee Hutchinson
made a major announcement of his own
Maddie's like my best pal and I've known
her since the beginning of Hollywood
week and you know she she actually
happens to be my girlfriend how did you
handle all these emotions you're in the
final two together which is competitive
how do you handle all that I mean it was
honestly it wasn't as challenging as you
might think
when I looked over at Maddie I was like
I win either way I really do I don't
feel any type of bitter or loss at all
I'm just so happy for her how long has
this been going on January 21st is the
day we met on Hollywood week and it was
the first day of Hollywood week and we
haven't really spent any time apart
since then how did you hide this
relationship well you know it was one of
those things where I didn't want it to
affect anything and I didn't want like
exploit you know my feelings forward
because they're very very real and you
know once vote was over I was like shoot
I want the world to know hey Liv are you
in love I mean you know I mean when you
remember the date you met somebody
sounds kind of serious yeah I remember I
remember looking at it I knew very
quickly
have you written any songs about Miss
Maddie yet you might just have to buy my
next album I mean a secret romance I'm
melting you can't write this stuff folks
but what an ending and Caleb is clearly
smitten he instagrammed this photo with
Maddie riding my girlfriend one American
Idol no one deserved it more than you
babe I am honored to know you and even
more honored to call you mine don't
forget about me I love you look even
Ryan Seacrest was tricked by this guys
meanwhile Dancing with the Stars has a
pair of new champs and wouldn't you know
it my boy Adam rib pawn and partner
Jenna Johnson won the Mirrorball trophy
last night Congrats rip on you guys can
actually catch our full interview with
the winners
et online.com very excited for him but
we got to move on a John Legend because
he is fresh off his performance at the
Billboard Music Awards and the crooner
reunited with his Jesus Christ Superstar
cast and crew yesterday that's where I
found out just how little sleep John is
getting these days from billboards to
promoting Jesus Christ Superstar tonight
and of course you got a new baby boy at
home I mean are you getting enough sleep
are you sleeping I'm not but it's okay
you know I'm starting to remember how it
was the first time around with Luna it's
all coming back to me
yeah and coming back to Christie - I
think you know this is that period in
his life and in our lives where you know
you get less sleep and you work a little
harder that's why I'm trying not to work
too much outside of the house because we
got a lot to do at home but some of
these things I had planned thinking he
was gonna come a little later but he
came like a few weeks early so I have to
do a little bit of work while he's here
but mostly I'll be home with Christie
and helping her with miles and yeah
Mouse Theodore is such a beautiful name
what's the significance behind that well
first of all we just wanted a name that
we liked a lot and like saying and felt
good about and we also wait til we see
the baby to decide what the name is
going to be for sure even though we had
some contenders going into it and then
we like to have some musical history in
their name so Lunas Luna Simone after
Nina Simone and then miles of course the
great Miles Davis so we like to have
some kind of musical connection in their
name and I think we chose wisely with
some of the greatest artists of all time
you have joked with us a few times that
Luna tends to be a little territorial
over you how is she feeling sharing this
baby with you or sharing you with the
baby I think she's just becoming aware
that he's the competition so I think
we'll see how that plays out but I think
it might be good because it's making her
you know she's like doing more to
ingratiate herself to us which means she
it might be a good thing for her to have
a little competition
listen Luna I got two younger sisters
and a little sibling rivalry never hurt
nobody
and neither does a little TV or a lot of
it summer is right around the corner and
with a preview of some of the most
anticipated TV shows of the season is
our resident TV expertly anti-glare I
can't believe it's that time of year
I am so ready meet you and Denny I hope
you were going to strut into summer like
a queen
because pose is coming to FX on June 3rd
and this edgy and history-making dramas
from super producer Ryan Murphy new
features TVs largest transgender series
regular cast as well as the largest
LGBTQ cast ever first scripted series
now it's a dance musical centered on
different segments of society in New
York in the 1980s including the culture
world I love a drag moment but not only
will we be introduced to some new faces
but there's some familiar ones as well
james van der beek kate mara Evan Peters
and all of them yeah and of course it
wouldn't be summer without the return of
younger I'm secretly obsessed with the
show I love show the TV Land series is
coming back for its fifth season and I'm
keeping my fingers crossed that this
could be the earring that Charles
discovers Eliza secret I don't like lies
Danny I agree I want them to be together
it's like I've been team Charles for the
past two seasons and I think we've been
waiting far too long for this one guys
ET was actually on the set with the
stars this week son Foster and Hilary
Duff they can't say much yet but they
tease that younger spit season is gonna
be a doozy
so if season 5 could be a book title
like what would you what would you call
it the first thing I thought it was no
roller coaster I know I thought it like
hold tight hold tight yeah what's that
is that saying like old-fashioned had to
like hold fast or go steady or cords
growing up oh growing up growing pains I
think that was already I don't think
about like a fast rule like it is Peter
explained it the best like every season
we've been like clicking up the slow
yeah oh you're the drop and then now
we're on the wall yeah I cannot wait
done
I already feel the butterflies in my
stomach watching that season yeah I'm so
excited
and any when it gets hot outside I
suggest you stay home and chill with
Netflix this time I see what you did
there
I love it
streaming service is dropping a ton of
new content including season 2 of glow
now this fan favorite a tea set dramedy
with Ali Bri and Betty Gilpin is one of
my favorites and we're also gonna have
season 2 of Marvel's Luke Cage to look
forward to I love that because there's
literally something for everybody but
you guys it's just a taste of the shows
to get excited for this summer we've got
a full list up at ET online.com so
thanks for that LeeAnn I think tomorrow
we'll have a preview of the biggest
summer movies so stay tuned guys make
sure you're following us here on
Facebook or subscribe to our YouTube
channel we'll see you tomorrow